wer findet rieger auch scheiße 1400
likes hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video habe vorgestern ein whatsapp rang
hochgeladen und darunter kamen sehr
viele kommentare und der frank ist
mittlerweile schon an die 700.000
aufrufe deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
ich gehe heute mal noch 10 kommentare
darunter ein weil darunter ein wenig
diskutiert wurde
luca toni ist bei mir gerade angekommen
ich weiß nicht wieso die 1000 ein oder
zwei likes auf den kommentaren aber ich
find's cool dass du den pulli bestellt
hast und dass er angekommen
falls hier überlegt etwas aus dem
minister vor zu kaufen und das soll
jetzt keine werbung sein sondern einfach
nur ein hilfreicher hinweis wie schon
mehrmals gefragt wird am ersten 12 der
komplette shop relaunch also als vom
irgendwie fünf neue produkte und ich
glaube sogar zwei t shirts werden
rausgenommen und wir haben neue designs
neue foto ist neue schnitte alles wird
anders deswegen wenn ihr wirklich was
bestellen wollte vielleicht am besten
auf den ersten 12 da wird auf 2.000
signiertes ticker geben also trikot
google müsste währung büro cooper hier
wenn ich habe wieder dieses komische
wackelt stativ haben start dieser moment
wenn man keine ahnung hat wer der typ
ist ich muss zugeben dass ich bis zu den
video days auch überhaupt keine ahnung
hatte was überhaupt musical ist oder wer
die leute das sind und dann habe ich mir
die helfer selber mal runtergeladen und
dann bin ich auch jetzt so langsam in
diese schiene rein gekommen um zu sehen
wer das so alles ist und dass alles
verstehen also ich glaube wenn ihr
wirklich wissen wollte wer das ist
müsstet ihr lukas selbst fragen aber für
mich ist es glaube ich einfach echt
nicht meine art mit musicali angefangen
und hat dann aber irgendwie auch selber
musik macht oder ich hab keine ahnung
ist korrekt und alles andere juckt
eigentlich nicht ich persönlich vereinen
konnten momentan echt gar nicht dieser
08 15 youtube konnten mir persönlich
gefällt der frühere gamings dieser echt
besser
naja aber macht das worauf der bock hast
ich halte mich jedoch jetzt erst mal
fern von diesem kann
kann momentan nichts mit deinen videos
anfang naja bis irgendwann mal schaue
kann ich komplett nachvollziehen also
wenn das seine meinung ist dann willig
sich davon natürlich auch überhaupt
nicht abraten oder dich irgendwie davon
versuchen zu überreden dass du irgendwie
weiter mein video aus meinen hochgeladen
content diejenigen die zu gemüte führen
soll es also alles cool und so aber ich
sehe selber dass ich mein konto in
letzter zeit ein bisschen verändert aber
das liegt wirklich einfach daran weil
ich derzeit wirklich überhaupt nichts
mit gaming irgendwie anfangen kann hatte
wie gesagt den kompletten september frei
und war dann halt nur hier zu hause bei
meiner familie und konnte dann halt nur
videos mit einer dslr kamera hier
aufnehmen und als ich dann wieder in
köln war und wieder vom pc sagt sie -
ich würde viel lieber von einer kamera
stehen und irgendwie ein anderes thema
war vielleicht jetzt irgendwie zocken
ich finde es irgendwie persönlicher
einfach so vor der kamera zu stehen und
nicht in so einem kleinen fenster oben
bei dem gaming video mir macht es
einfach mehr spaß und man sollte das auf
youtube machen woran man spaß hat ich
dachte nicht dazu zwingen mein konnte
zuschauen aber ich werde mein konnten
nicht verändern sondern immer das machen
worauf ich spaß habe und das wird auch
vielleicht in zwei wochen wieder gaming
sein beispiel ein englisches roulette
jeder zweite leidet muss mich abonnieren
verpiss dich von meinem kanal und
kommentiert nicht mehr danke du hast
nicht mit lukas geschrieben sonst
würdest du auch die sprachnachrichten an
machen bäume ohne willst das war damals
geschrieben ich muss übrigens immer hier
dran fassen weil das ding sonst wirklich
einfach so wackeln würde der malz
geschriebene kommentar war all das ist
fake du spielst gar keine
sprachnachrichten ab sagt ihr bescheuert
als wenn ich mir so etwas ausdenken man
dir das hier haben wir jetzt endlich wie
man alle die irgendwie mal in jork
blabla wolf hier lest euch durch jetzt
spiele ich hier sogar die
sprachnachricht ab wie kommt s schädeln
ansprüchen wie gesprächen da wir unsere
enthalten die das video jahren kommt und
da hab ich einfach geantwortet dass ich
will mir dann kommt dadurch gelebt haben
so viele gesehen habe die irgendwie mein
das space also ich weiß ich was ich euch
noch zeigen soll ich habe ein vorleser
ich hab hier
ein kauf genommen dass vom nicht mehr
her was als wenden und dann das
verschicken
also ob ich mal video sehen kann und wer
link geschickt also keine ahnung wenn
ihr meint es ist fake sein was seid ihr
für menschen als wenn ich einfach
irgendeine personen nehmen würde in
meinem handy ihnen halt gegen den anlass
allein speichern würde und dann hält es
das macht überhaupt keinen sinn und
nicht jeder war irgendwie so freut mich
dort einfach geschrieben ja ok dass das
war nicht lukas wollte habe ich auch so
geschrieben hey das café ich will mit
dir schreiben du oft war gar nicht auch
nicht nachvollziehen
auf so eine scheiße zu verbreiten und
zwar ist also nicht an euch alle die das
ist was was sagt das wollt ihr wer
findet rieger auch scheiße 1400 likes
ich finds total unmenschlich wenn man
von jemandem behauptet dass er scheiße
sei oder behindert oder was weiß ich
irgendwelche anderen wörter die gar
keine beleidigungen sind als beleidigung
benutzen obwohl man diese personen gar
nicht kennt also ich hab mit solchen
leuten nichts anfangen die so etwas
negatives verbreiten ich habe das über
mega pablo auch gesagt dass ich ihn
persönlich nicht kenne deswegen will ich
nicht beleidigen oder irgendwie angehen
aber seinen content ich halt einfach
beschissen so das kann ich also sagen
weil ich das überhaupt nicht mag was er
hochlädt und so gehen nicht setzt sich
das eigentlich auch auf lukas beziehen
also das was er auf musical die
hochwertig auch nicht so und seine musik
ist jetzt auch nicht die musikrichtung
die ich mit jedem tag zu gemüte führen
aber die person die dahintersteckt finde
ich eigentlich recht nett also ich
verstehe nicht wie man menschen bewerten
kann die man nicht kennt das aber das
ist typisch im internet dass ich leute
hinter dem profilbild verstecken und
deswegen was sagen luca dein ernst hast
keinen bock auf des lecks oder leute ich
habe vor zweieinhalb jahren dieses video
hochgeladen und zwar deaktiviere ich die
bewertungen ab heute für eine woche ist
jetzt wahrscheinlich dass das zuhören
und wir gerade schon gefragt haben habe
ich in diesem video gesagt dass ich für
eine woche die bewertungen aussteller
das ist nicht weil ich angst vor
displays haben oder keinen bock auf des
life oder irgendwie nicht gerettet
werden
sondern einfach weil ich bessere
kommentar unter meinen videos haben will
ich habe keinen bock darauf so
kommentare zu fliegen wie beispielsweise
jeder zweite leidet muss mich abonnieren
und deswegen habe ich die bewertungen
hausgemacht und ich werde die
bewertungen auch in vier tage wieder
anmachen um einfach zu sehen ob sich die
kommentare dann regeneriert haben oder
ob das alles irgendwie was gebracht hat
habe ich habe die bewertungen nicht
ausgemacht weil ich kein bock auf disks
habe sondern einfach nicht bessere
kommentare wollte weise zusammengefasst
und ich habe auch schon auf so viele
leute die kommentar geschrieben haben
uns so gefragt habe er ist kein wort
leistet ist leitete war massa auf
arabisch und so oft reagieren
abgeschrieben echter verfolgt vor allem
tag vor zwei tagen wieder schubladen
coup das doch bitte an aber irgendwie
verstehen dass die leute nicht also
bitte freunde die wir bei der zuschauer
sind auf das video von vor zwei tagen
gesehen haben wenn ihr so kommentare
seht wie von wegen joel hatte denn die
lions displays aus der puszta was
schreibt ihnen einfach dass ich gerade
so 1 test durchführen verweist sie auf
ein video von vor drei tagen giori lhota
aber den humor hat dich so krass
verändert dass ich dich nicht wirklich
mehr fahren und auch klingelte und eine
videos werden tag zu tag immer
schlechter hat auf instagram sogar meine
fanpage für dich die ich auch aufgegeben
habe weil ich einfach nicht mehr feiern
also erst mal wenn du deine fanpage
aufgeben hast so das ist deine
entscheidung da kann ich jetzt nicht
sagen okay ist scheiße oder ist cool
oder keine ahnung was du das muss jeder
für sich selbst entscheiden aber du hast
du beginn gesagt dass mich mein humor
verändert hat aber nur örtlich zu cross
von renault das verstehe ich nicht weil
wie kann mein humor mich verändern warum
stellt mich jeder so als wäre ich jetzt
in übelster [ __ ] geworden nur weil
ich mehr vor der kamera stehe als bei
meinem rechner real talk was wollt ihr
nicht ihr die das gerade schauen und
wirklich mich als person feiern aber ihr
die nur beim konzert gefeiert habt nur
dass ich wirklich von meinem rechner saß
und gezockt habe das heißt doch dass ihr
nicht die videos wegen mir geschockt
sondern nur weil ich gezockt haben oder
weil ich irgendwie vom rechner dazu
sagen weil ich nun klein gesehen habt
und was weis ich finde einfach in
letzter zeit sehr oft hier zu hause bei
meiner familie deshalb sehr viele
private gründe
die will ich euch gar nicht sagen aber
deswegen kommen viele von diesem videos
wo ich vor der kamera stehe und du bist
ein c keine abonnenten von daher sei
aber kein nicht von ändern und wenn
leute sagen ich würde mich verändern
alter dann kennt ihr nicht einfach nicht
ich mache seit 2 jahren ein studium an
jetlags abgebaut werden irgendwo del
leben und mit einem lambo irgendwo rum
fahren hey ich bin ganz normaler junge
und mach mein konto das rov phoca sorry
ich will ich das ganze in so einen real
talk video irgendwie in seine schiene
hin abfällt aber mich fragt ab wenn wir
leute vorwerfen ich würde mich verändern
weil ihr seid die einzigen die das von
mir behaupten und die kennt nicht nicht
mal versucht das bitte noch mal mit
lukas rieder ich denke ich werde das
nicht noch mal ne lukas versuchen weil
ich es ja aufgelöst habe und ich denke
die nächsten mal wenn ich da noch
irgendwas komische schreiben sollte dass
ihm die ansatzweise aus dem songtext ist
wirklich direkt auf aufmerksam werden
lukas meinte schon dass er irgendwie mit
der ende november in köln ist dann
wollten uns immer treffen und wollte
leichten video aufnehmen ich weiß nicht
was ihr davon haltet weil jetzt der
große kommentare kann mit über 1000
leicht von wegen dass ihr lukas einfach
scheiße findet oder so ich weiß nicht
vielleicht nehmen wir das auch
vielleicht zog ich mal gegen ihn runde
tiefer oder so ich weiß nicht da ich war
coole ideen schreibt mir bitte euro mehr
liche meinung dazu die kommentare ich
bin ich so was sehen wie das ist dumm
schwul ich die runde nicht an sondern
wirklich einfach eure meinung ob ihr
wollt oder nicht das was ihr familie
meine damen und herren ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen wenn es getan hat schreibt
schon mal die kommentare der bitte nicht
übel dass ich gerade so ein bisschen ich
sag mal hats erfüllter geworden bin weil
dem einen kommentar aber mich fax ab
wenn leute sagen ich hätte nicht
verändert obwohl ich diese person gar
nicht kennen und die verstecken sich
hinter irgendwelchen profilbildern und
irgendwelche namen im internet deswegen
ich weiß nicht konzentriere mich auf das
positive auch eure positiven kommentare
auf konstruktive kritik aber nicht auf
solche vorwürfe die einfach überhaupt
keine hand und fuß habe nicht mehr
gerade schon selber wie ich mich so ein
bisschen verharrt für die ganze zeit ich
muss jetzt auf den geburtstag meiner
tante deswegen ich bin noch in der
rotation bei 25 minuten
tut mir leid dass ich so lange von
gelabert hat ich hoffe ihr möglich
trotzdem laufen wenn ich mag euch und
ich mal positive sachen und wenn ich auf
das negative konzentrieren und noch
weiter mit dem auf youtube weil ich spaß
habe